se podría pensar que el hecho de que el
2022 no haya sido el año más cálido
podría indicar que el calentamiento de
la tierra no sigue un avance lineal es
esto así O cómo deberíamos leer estos
datos para comprender la magnitud de la
emergencia climática
bueno Rodrigo muchísimo gusto saludarte
la verdad es que efectivamente los datos
hay que leerlos cierto en de una forma
que te muestren
espacios temporales mucho más amplios
obviamente pero es importantísimo saber
y por lo mismo cierto esta noticia viene
acompañada con este sexenio es decir es
el sexto año más cálido ahí entonces una
progresión
no significa cierto o sea hay todavía el
el 2022 Fue entonces
un año que tuvo una temperatura mucho
mayor que el promedio Qué significa eso
Entonces que la temperatura
efectivamente viene subiendo que haya
sido más baja tal vez que otros años
previos es
solamente una coincidencia ahora
entendamos también que el cambio
climático y que y que el aumento de la
temperatura no solamente causa cierto
que el el el este aumento de la
temperatura per se pero sino también una
serie de otras acciones que es lo que
hemos visto también como hacer tormentas
mucho más crueles o también como por
ejemplo lo que tiene que ver con los
cambios en las corrientes del océano
etcétera precisamente hablando de esos
fenómenos quería seguir porque Europa
está viviendo Un inicio de año seco y
cálido en pleno invierno sin embargo las
acumulaciones de nieve en las masas
rocosas de Norteamérica son muy
abundantes hace pocos años sin embargo
California sufría fenómenos de sequía en
invierno vamos hacia un escenario de
fenómenos impredecibles y extremos
exactamente Ese es justamente las
características y eso es una de las
cosas que más preocupa es lo que hemos
visto en California es un ejemplo que tú
Rodrigo muy bien decías Un ejemplo muy
claro de hemos tenido la concentración
de lluvias en un en un momento lluvias
que incluso prácticamente superado a
años normales cierto pero en un tiempo
muy específico muy corto lo cual hace
además también que esa lluvia cierto No
es que no es que la lluvia o la cantidad
de agua sea lo necesario esa agua tiene
que venir también
esparcida en un en un tiempo durante el
año durante la temporada sin embargo
ahora tenemos estas lluvias que caen en
cierto en un par de días y por lo tanto
el agua no alcanza a ser absorbida por
la tierra sobre todo en tierras que
venía Muy seca producto de la situación
que tú también mencionaba la sequía
constante que había vivido en California
eso es justamente una de las
características estos eventos extremos
que están haciendo
mucho daño producto de que
es como una acumulación digamos de
alguna forma de de de de de de de de de
de de de característica relativamente
típicas o no pero entonces que vienen y
y tienen efectos tremendamente fuertes
sobre las poblaciones humanas sobre los
ecosistemas y por lo tanto es difícil a
la vez también predecir estas
situaciones en el largo plazo estamos
viendo cambios graduales en algunas
partes como la pérdida del hielo y en
otras partes estamos viendo algunos
cambios que son bien extremos habla
usted precisamente de la pérdida del
hielo también en el informe se citan las
masas heladas del hielo del Ártico y del
Antártico cómo está siendo el avance del
derretimiento de este hielo y Qué
consecuencias estamos viendo ya
justamente el estudio se refiere
efectivamente a la pérdida de hielo y a
la
lo cual está causado principalmente por
las masas de agua también cálidas
acordemos no no solamente la atmósfera
la que está calentando gran parte y de
hecho los científicos vienen diciendo
aproximadamente el 90% del exceso de
temperatura en la atmósfera la recibe
también en el mar y por lo tanto eso
también esas masas de agua caliente van
derritiendo el hielo mucho más
rápidamente y en algunos de estos
lugares particularmente como en como
hemos visto en el Ártico y en la
antártica las más salieron se van
derritiendo desde abajo donde está el
agua como digo más cálida y lo cual está
llevando un derretimiento aún más
profundo O aún más rápido el que
esperábamos lo cual significa también
entonces que cambia la la química del
del océano Pero además también cambia
Obviamente el nivel del mar que una de
las cosas más preocupantes que conocemos
del de los efectos del cambio climático